president biden is heading to new
england this morning hoping to show how
a more than trillion dollar
infrastructure package will help one
small town in particular the president
signed that bill into law yesterday at a
big white house ceremony hours later the
president had a long-awaited virtual
meeting with china's president xi
jinping their video conference addressed
some of the growing economic and
military tensions between the two
countries and ed o'keefe is at the white
house force tracking it all this was a
long meeting ed good morning sure was
tony good morning white house says it
went on for about three and a half hours
and describes it as a substantial and
respectful back and forth that was
straightforward but anyone looking for a
big breakthrough may be disappointed
a late night at the white house and an
early morning in beijing all countries
have to play by the same rules of the
road
why the united states is always going to
stand up for our interests and values
she said he's also seeking cooperation
we should each run our domestic affairs
well and work together to advance the
noble cause of world peace and
development a senior administration
official said the two leaders discussed
human rights climate change kovit 19 and
the importance of transparency amid a
pandemic economic commitments and
china's military activity around taiwan
the white house official wouldn't say if
china's hypersonic missile test in july
was discussed
recent satellite images show mock
american warships in a chinese desert
built possibly for target practice
gary locke who served as ambassador to
china during the obama administration
said china's growing military power is
cause for concern what they're doing
with respect to taiwan
what they're doing to
build up military bases in the south
china sea so we need to have frank
discussions one discussion left off the
table a formal invitation to the beijing
olympics today
we're finally getting this done
and on monday president biden said the
u.s will be even more competitive
against china thanks to passage of the
bipartisan infrastructure bill
because of this law next year will be
the first year in 20 years american
infrastructure investment will grow
faster than china's
today the president's set to continue
his celebration of that infrastructure
bill by visiting rural new hampshire to
talk about how the legislation is going
to help rebuild thousands of bridges
across the country tomorrow he heads to
michigan to talk about electric vehicles
why new hampshire and michigan because
they're set to hold competitive contests
in next year's midterm elections gail
all right thank you very much